what wait what do that what does that
mean no wait please what does it mean
for the
camera I'm trying I don't know what that
word I'm not an Arab speaker I need to
know what the name okay thank you so
muhamad sits on the throne with
Allah it's
God it's
God
did we're done with the question you
affirm that Muhammad is going to sit on
the throne of Allah now one of his
attributes hold on come over here it's
okay come on it's okay it's F so one of
his attributes which you affirm to be
which is above everyone correct Allah
yeah one of his attribut is being above
everyone correct so if Muhammad is going
to sit on the throne of Allah with him
on that same Throne okay now no longer
Allah is going to be above everyone yet
they're going to be at the same he as
together not not only that from AB Becca
what does he say he says I got you I'll
bring it up I got
everything I got everything I got
everything there you go by the way if
you want to support the daa man s da you
know also just go to his patreon pay
$1,000 to learn how to blashe against
Islam
doab who knows come here he get funed
everywhere YouTube Tik Tok you
name hisp look at his
drip hey move in move in move
in what does it say
here okay this is a chain of narration
right what does he
say there you go what is until they
touch each other okay until they touch
each other and what is this of the
Hadith read it please for us it's what
there we go beautiful so what is your
cont so so if if Muhammad is going to
sit on the throne of Allah and no longer
Allah is going to be above everyone and
they're going to touch each other
physically that means they're
associating Corners together okay that
means Allah is not going to be
above nobody else okay he's not going to
be above Muhammad they're going to be
associating Partners together while
Muhammad is sitting on that on thatone
who said where does it say Muhammad will
be a partner to Allah what does it say
in the partner wa does it have to be
a logically speak
yeah fake laugh where does it say
Muhammad is going to be a partner to
Allah where does it say that partner
hold on let me ask you this question
don't ask me a question show me I got
you show me that muhamed will be I got
you
when he says the high praise
worthy what does that mean Allah is
going to make M if Allah is going to
make Muhammad sit with him on that same
throne with him on that
same I'm asking to clarify to clarify he
speaks perfectl you said he sits on the
AR you don't need to clarify
speak no he's
not so he sits with him so he's going to
yes with him on that same that Allah and
Muhammad are going to be partners show
me they're going to be partners I'm
showing you logically speaking sitting
next to someone I'm standing next to you
are we Partners what wait wait wait wait
hold on no no no hold on are we Partners
yes hold on hold Partners yes we are
Partners but but hold on when you touch
that person aren't you closest to him
already aren't you on that sameel are
you saying closeness equals partnership
no no no when one hold on when I touch
you am I at the same he as you I think
it's mud
am I next to you what am I at the same
high as you next to you or am I above
you okay it doesn't matter am I above
you or underne you it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter oh it doesn't matter guys
no it doesn't matter where's the boom it
doesn't matter now guys no no let's hear
respon let's go ahead and respon sitting
next to someone does not equal
partnership number one number two the
Throne of Allah is what is it created or
uncreated it's actually created but
guess what but guess what according to
the Quran thr of Allah will be honored
and it's actually honored by the Angels
okay so if the Throne of Allah is
honored by the angels and Muhammad is
going to sit on it are you telling me
that Muhammad is going to be honored as
well by the Angels it never says that
well it does say that here no no answer
my question I got you I'm going to bring
the verse is the throne created I don't
know why are we going this way it
doesn't matter the is created or not it
is created of course it's within the
creation on it he said the throne is
created is Muhammad created huh is
Muhammad created is Muhammad created
according to you guys yes but you to you
guys according ACC does ACC
to mamad created not not a problem
Muhammad is created I'll go I will go
with you hold on
cre created things what is the issue
what is the issue I'll tell you what's
the issue I'll tell you what's the issue
if you believe in Allah okay being
himself God obviously separated from
from all the creatures right and you
consider Muhammad as a creature as well
as a prophet as a creature if Allah is
going to make Muhammad sit with him on
that same high level together and
they're going to touch each other
physically when one of Allah his
attributes is being being above every
where does it say they'll talk each
other I just show I just show
it he what does mean
I think it's touch
maybe there's
the go ahead and deal with that is what
is the issue what problem do you have of
one created being sitting next to
another got let me think go ahead one
one thing that's created sitting on
another created thing what is the issue
number number three answer this what is
the object of warning I got you answer
what is the object you're asking
something got VI can I please ask you a
question viation you said you said you
said what is the problem of a created
being sitting with God is that your
question do you have an issue with that
I do have an issue with that but you
will sit next you will sit on the god
according to Revelations run don't R so
let's be running to the Bible right now
watch this be consistent let's not you
see guys how he's actually running to
the Bible and he can't even deal with
the argument this is what they this is
what we call What Muslim Shuffle there
we go I called it now now let me ask
hold on now if Muhammad is going to sit
on the throne of Allah with Allah and
you okay I'll go with you that the
Throne of Allah is considered to be
creation that's not a problem but do the
angels are the Angels going to carry the
throne while they're honoring the throne
as do they do they carry the throne
prior to Muhammad sitting on are they
going to be honored the yes or no sure
what we'll get to the point what problem
is it what is the problem I'll show you
what's the problem watch this guys watch
this what is the what is the p and not P
let me let me finish what the I'll let
you speak go ahead give us the p and not
yesterday the throne his maest I made a
mistake it's not about that I I
corrected my so what is it go ahead expl
go and L so if the angels will be
killing that thr and they will be
honoring whoever that will be sitting on
that Throne if Allah is going to make
Muhammad sit with him now one of Allah's
attributes let's not forget one of one
of Allah attrib is being which is above
everyone this is an attribute now if
Muhammad is going to sit with him on
that same high level now they're can
associate parnership not only that
Muhammad is sharing the same attribute
as of Allah being at the same high level
not only that they're going to be
touching each other physically now Allah
is no longer be above everyone what
attribute does Muhammad share with now
congratulations he's touching them above
touching someone he's above everyone
above
everyone you consider which is above
everyone if I if I touch you am I an
attribute of you now wait where
is that's what you
said foring I know I know the Christians
can't do that but I can't
you guys got to go back back we got back
up this way that way right there right
there there
you are you can you hear bro you he what
I I said
nothing I just said so you's given us
something new that we haven't seen the
last 14400 years so is there small yeah
I do 100% he knows it he knows it this
is why I'm actually having this
conversation bring a
god well hold on hold on hold on it
doesn't even have to be for saying that
you will be worshiping muhamad if Allah
if Allah himself okay will be okay with
that why Muhammad's going to sit with
him then you know what he doesn't have
to say you have two objects of worship
you have exactly one second out of the
level out of 1400 years of scholarship
name one scholar that said Muslims will
worship what do that got to do
AR let me show let me show you the
mistake that you're making no no you
know you speaking of both of us I'm
about to say my question when I to say
this yeah I'm I'm going go ahead
beautifully so this is the problem with
what he's asking so now he's basically
he's asking you he's asking you him to
moderate speak perfect to give an
Islamic scholar what the hell is this
perfect Engish hold on guys guys listen
listen up listen listen actually asking
a question he's asking Sil to provide an
Islamic scholar that would actually
debunk Islam the way that Sil is doing
no Islam scholar is going to do that
they're not going to give the same a lot
the the same conclusion as Sil is going
to go they're going to stop at a line
Sil actually crosses that line to us all
the way to a logical conclusion what you
have to do is explain it you have to
explain how is it not sh yeah refute it
and or explain how is it not
that that Allah is touching creation
which is Muhammad and Muhammad is
sharing the throne with Allah sh the
attri saying the same attribute being
above everyone above the throne and
right he's above all of creation you
have to explain how that's not Shar and
the Throne of divinity also don't forget
that sh of divinity beautiful again you
said for some
Reas perfect right there you said
because said because Muhammad will be
honored he will be worshiped that's not
what I said I never said that I said I
said hold on hold on all I said I'm
looking
here here I got them but I'm like right
there exactly you know
why the reason why I said they will be
at the same high level as as Allah and
Muhammad and them both being at the same
high level of course I can show you
100% I got it on the same level hold on
I got you hold on I got you
so hold on hold on hold on just one
second by the way Danny you can move the
camera what does it mean with him okay
show me he'll sit with him okay let's
actually go to to since he take him as
an authority by by by the way
yester he agreed yesterday not only that
but we had Omar that agreed with the
Arabic reading he said yeah yeah it says
with him and yes it's
hold on it's
a hold
on know
read
correct volume 6
2 he's he's what he's quoting a verse
from the
AY which Allah will give Muhammad the
high praise worthy station according to
79 what does it say
what does it mean what does refer to
here
historically
also wait wait did you guys hear say it
again it's what it's
what look at you don't listen to don't
listen to them what is
it it says what no no no don't listen to
this it says what do it wait what does
that what does that mean say what it no
wait please what does it mean for the
camera I don't know what I'm not an
Arabic speaker I need to know what the
okay thank you so Muhammad sits on the
throne with
Allah let him let him answer or let me
answer
no is different Allah
ascending with oh go ahead bro Al the
ascending is a different type of
Ascension to Allah and Muhammad so
Muhammad doesn't Ascend in the same way
that Allah
ascends number two what we talking I
don't know that is so
irrelevant I think I think that's what
they whispered to Central to say they
told him to say
[Applause]
arss that wasn't even close
that
was does
not let's just make this very simple Sil
it doesn't even have to do anything with
the so let's Grant mamed sits on let's
Grant it let's Grant it let's
gram sit on the what do you
mean there this hold on you're telling
me hold
for the Tik Tok you got to be that way I
got you for
the got to rope them up clear English
say granted I'm asking when we speak
Central can you slide to your right
slide Central to the right we all
talking here what are you talking about
Talking
Top nobody clarify okay
nobody let's make it easy what is the p
and not p hold on on you said you said
list granted to you are you saying that
is not a h up on us what is that I don't
care give me the p and not P of how it
equates to us worshiping muham bro go
ahead you said you said L bran I don't
want you to run away from it I yes are
you accepting it are you AC yes I now
tell me the p
and since you're actually okay there's a
on Tope of sh do you agree get I'm going
to ask one more time give me the p and
not P to how it equates to sh there is a
different type of sh do you agree give
me I'm s give me the P tr get to my
point and this is what they do what is
sh do you give me the definition there's
a different type of sh you agree Give me
the definition I got you but there's
different type of sh you agree Give me
the definition of I'm trying to I'm
asking you so I can clarify Give me the
definition of is there a different type
of shirk yes or no give me the defition
okay he doesn't want to he doesn't want
to question I got I got we'll actually
help him out let's we'll help him out
when you associate your partners this is
considered to be a shk when you do a
prostration when you prostrate this is
considered to be a shk this is some of
the sherks okay that I actually
mentioned now since I gave you that now
let's go back to the question okay if
he's going to if he's going to make
Muhammad the one that one of his
attributes which you consider Allah's
attribut you agree above everyone yes
yes beautiful so if he's going to sit
with him on that same Throne Allah is
going to share an attribute of with
Muhammad so now no longer Allah is going
to be above everyone they're going to be
at the same high level not only that
according to they're going to be
touching each other now let me tell you
something if Allah is above Muhammad how
is he going to touch him how is it going
to have to be at the same high level for
them to touch each
other now I would like you to please
show me how this is not considered to be
a Sher beautiful this is not guys you
know associate and partners with each
other Beau go ahead I asked s to give me
a pee and not he doesn't know what that
is he has absolutely no idea this guy
doesn't even know where he is what is
your definition of sh you you stay quiet
okay you now okay you said sh is bowing
down to somebody
correct be
quiet you said be consist I'm answering
your question yes you said bowing down
is worshiping correct well well
according to you guys okay according to
you guys it's one of them to uh watch
the boom hold on no no no no no
no watch the from The argum Watch the
watch theal deal deal with with what I
actually said and what what I brought
off from when they're going to touch
each other deal with that I got you
watch the show me how it's not
considered to be a sh said bowing down
and prostrating is
it could be it could be considered to be
yes it could be is that correct it could
be what is that he's stealing me bro uh
you about our frustration you consider
frustration as so his argument is
committing sh is bowing down to
someone wasting time this he said when
you bow down you're prostrating to
someone when Muhammad sits on the throne
who will be prostrating who will be
prostrating to who who will be Prost
will anybody be prostrating what are you
talking about got don't R we got it what
don't what you what is he talking about
does Muhammad sit on the throne and the
deal of judgment who will be worshiping
it doesn't matter who will be bowing
down it doesn't matter will there be any
creation to bow down you don't have to
you know why you don't have to okay you
know you you want to know why you don't
have to I'll tell you why you don't have
to hold on so Muhammad sits on the Thro
bowing down is considered sh but there's
nobody to Bow Down's so who's committing
sh hold on you're running you're running
from it I'll tell you why okay you want
my on the right now you want my respond
go ahead okay beautiful so we both
agreed that in the day of judgment that
he was going to he's going to sit on
that same throne with Allah now do you
believe that the Quran is
uncreated see
how no SP 15 minutes
or yes or no it's my turn no no no we're
not done we're not done we're not done
you see guys how he's R oh my God logic
[Music]